one of the singers of the 20th century
Aretha Franklin passed away late last
week at the age of 76 really one of the
amazing voices of our time and there
were countless great tributes to her old
videos of her performance performances
over the years spreading virally and in
the middle of it Fox News put up a
picture of a different black woman
during a tribute to Aretha Franklin Fox
News instead put up a picture of singer
Patti LaBelle during the tribute that
they did to Aretha Franklin you'll
notice in the background of the picture
that were showing our television
audience right now that's not a wreath
of Franklin that's Patti LaBelle from
when she's sang for the Obamas at the
White House in 2014 and Fox News put out
an apology statement which arguably
makes it even worse they said quote we
sincerely apologize to Aretha Franklin's
family and friends our intention was to
honor the icon using a secondary image
of her performing with Patti LaBelle in
the full-screen graphic but the image of
Miss Franklin was obscured in that
process which we deeply regret the
apology is complete and total BS it is
true that Aretha Franklin and Patti
LaBelle both sang at this event for the
Obamas a few years ago but the apology
implies that they were both in the
picture that Fox News used like they
were both on stage at the same time but
Aretha Franklin ended up being covered
up in the picture there is no record of
Patti LaBelle and Aretha Franklin being
on stage at the same time meaning that
the apology is a total lie and the
apology is just as harmful as what they
did using the wrong persons picture
because it is a demonstrable lie and I
get that mistakes happen on Fox News the
mistakes often relate to the mislabeling
of Democrats and black people but at
least give a real apology because this
leak becomes a trump-like lie it's a lie
about something seemingly
inconsequential like yeah it's a mistake
it's a cringe-worthy mistake but it's a
mistake and mistakes happen in
television production but then they
continue to lie by saying Oh Aretha was
also in the picture with Patti LaBelle
but she was obscured no there's no
evidence they were on stage
at the same time and I guess we should
look at the positive which is at least
they didn't put up a picture of black
comedian Tracy Morgan during the Aretha
Frank Franklin interview I mean
obviously mistakes do happen but I think
that if you're Fox News you have to go
out of your way to make sure that they
don't happen one because you're a big
news organization with a large outreach
but also because you kind of have a
history of doing this kind of stuff they
don't like you know the anti-black bias
and in just you know not treating
African Americans as we'd like them to
mislabelling any Republican who has
committed a crime as a Democrat but then
of course issuing a correction later not
any Republican but it's happened a few
too many times to be a coincidence yeah
and I think that this is some of what's
been normalized by Donald Trump
which is that when I would like to say
reasonable people or businesses make a
mistake they just apologize right they
don't say we apologize if anybody was
offended they don't cover or explain the
mistake with a lie you just say we made
a mistake and we're really sorry for
that and we're gonna work to make sure
it doesn't happen again
Trump's unwillingness to just say I
didn't tell the truth or I said the
wrong thing or I was wrong about
something
it's emboldened media outlets like Fox
News to do the exact same thing is yeah
the story continues if you just outright
say that you apologize then the story
wraps up it's over with it doesn't last
for a week or two like this one is and
like many of trumps are the problem is
anybody who identifies that there may be
any bad faith to Fox News here and
attributing any bad faith to Fox News
you're the problem the same way that
anybody that identifies racism as part
of the problem because you are quote
playing the race card that's ultimately
what the real truth is for many of these
Fox News viewers